all right hello everyone we have seconds
we have two second-year students here
poly underman and Omid Ashish Bonnie
here with us today
hello Polly and Omid is so excited to
have both of you here Thanks thank you
for joining us so can we start by you
both briefly introducing yourselves and
talk a little bit about your backgrounds
so what were you each doing before
business school and what are your goals
after graduation and then we can open up
to some questions from the audience
sure so before the GSB I was working in
the nonprofit space at the Environmental
Defense Fund I focused on sustainable
agriculture mostly in India and then
later on domestic environmental issues I
came to the GSB to work on corporate
sustainability and I'm hoping to go into
that it's post-graduation yeah so I'm
originally from Germany I started I
graduated from undergrad from a business
degree in Germany in Argentina and
started working for Google in Ireland it
was there for two years
then I transferred to the US was another
four years in the u.s. working on the
Latin American market doing cloud
computing partnerships distribution
partnerships across Latin America which
was a was a was a great time but it felt
like I was ready for some for the next
kind of phase of growth and that's when
when I decided to apply to business
school and came here and very much with
the goal of pursuing entrepreneurial
entrepreneurial endeavors and that's
kind of what I'm doing as I'm as we
approaching the last seven eight months
of our a part time as a second year MBA
sorry okay let's look at a couple of
questions so first with our first
question is actually coming from a
college senior from India this person
writes I am applying for the Stanford
MBA deferred enrollment what are the
variety of qualities that are looked
into an applicant applying directly from
college for the deferred enrollment
program so I can take this one so we do
encourage college seniors to imply apply
to our program we that is the earliest
time that you are able to apply to the
MBA program and we're looking for the
exact same things we were looking for
the intellectual vitality the
demonstrated leadership potential as
well as your personal
and contributions we take all of that
into consideration and consider the fact
that you are a college senior so we are
still looking for the leadership but
maybe instead of a full-time job maybe
we are being able to see that in your
extracurricular activities that you've
been able to do on campus or any work in
your community or if you've been able to
do research or any internships that
you've had so we are still looking for
those same qualities in all of our
deferred people who are applying for
different enrollment as well our next
question for our students is what did
each of you do to fulfill your global
requirement wanna start yeah happy to so
before school even began we had a new
program it was it was a pilot when I
started it was called a global seminar
and that was kind of two weeks before
school began and with I think about 25
other incoming mb1 students we went to
South Korea it was a trip led by two MBA
twos so students that were year ahead of
us
and that in itself was sufficient to
satisfy the global requirement but I
really personally believe that the trips
you do with your fellow MBA classmates
are not only some of the most memorable
experiences from our time here but also
incredible learning opportunities I feel
like the given the depth of these trips
and the intensity at which you're
getting to know a country and its
economy and its business landscape I I
really wanted to do more so not only did
I go on another trip to China I also
ended up currently organizing a study
trip to Italy coming up in March so that
was my experience similarly I was on a
global seminar before the school year
started so that was for me to Brazil and
it was an incredible opportunity to
connect really deeply with my classmates
before even coming to school and we had
this wonderful kind of safety net and
community as we were adjusting to life
at the GSB it was led by two second-year
students and they were a wonderful
resource as all the questions start
pouring in when you get here it was also
a wonderful opportunity to learn about
Brazil I've never been and so our
subject was poverty alleviation and by
all sustainability is very relevant to
me and so we met with people across the
nonprofit's in politics and then in
corporations and so got to learn a lot i
likewise couldn't get enough although
that didn't fulfill the requirement and
so I went on a global study trip to
Mexico over Christmas and something that
the global study trips really highlight
is the the value of the network within
the GSB so our second year trip leaders
were able to organize meetings with the
president Mexico with RIT with the
foreign minister with the head of
Central Bank I'm gonna write a really
interesting non profits and
entrepreneurs still couldn't get enough
so I actually led the global seminar
this summer to Argentina and Peru and
was able to create that experience for
incoming Ambulance in this experience of
doing more than one global experience
it's quite common for our students so
great okay the next question we have is
what is life like for students bringing
their partners or families with them if
you have personal experience or even
from your husband this we both came here
as not married singles we do however
have a lot of classmates that either
came with her esos which stands for
significant others or without the rest
but with the children we had those we
have those cases as well I would
generally like to highlight that the
over the GSB community given its
relatively small size in comparison to
other schools is a very inclusive
community where you will very often find
other students reaching out and trying
to help and trying to help be it I heard
just yesterday I was sitting over dinner
the Germans were coming together last
night to celebrate our cultural heritage
but and one of my classmates was talking
she has three children and she was
talking about how her husband had never
actually sat in one of the GSB classes
and and I asked why and she said well
because of babysitting and I and I said
you know I'd love to be your babysitter
so that your husband can attend the
class I think it's just a very inclusive
community and truth be spoken I think
the experience is slightly different you
you just have a different priority if
you have
husband or wife at home and or children
but I think still there are many ways
you can get a lot of learnings out of
this experience and yeah it's just a
slightly different one admittedly add a
couple of small pieces I think a lot of
the families who do come here they live
in and graduate student housing and they
do nanny shares and there's a common
place based on terms of raising kids
there is a lot of support and they tend
to pool resources in a truly business
school way to kind of get through the
day and create more space and more
community the other thing is SOS are
very integrated into the culture I spend
more time with some of my classmates SOS
than I do with them there's a lot of
events after school hours even during
school hours where SOS are welcomed both
academic and and more for fun and so
they really are as much of a part of the
experience that they as they want to be
great another question about admissions
here so how much weight is given to
one's academics and work experience
while applying for an MBA from Stanford
and how much weight for extracurricular
initiatives so for us we are not waiting
anything or place any stronger emphasis
on one part of your application more
than the other
we do read your application completely
holistically we are we look at you and
treat you as a whole person so there's
not one thing in your application that
will be weighed more than the other we
are really trying to figure out all of
the things that you will be able to
bring and contribute to the class okay
so the next question back to our
students is can the students talk a
little bit more about classes that they
took outside of the GSB and maybe
specifically at the d.school the design
school sure so I am a joint degree
student in the earth and environmental
sciences program so I've taken a number
of classes there one of which was a
design school class on the food system I
mean each class is going to be different
I loved both of the classes I took a
food economics class in a class up at D
school and the main thing I will say is
it's a great chance to connect with
people outside the business school we
call it the bubble and it is hard to get
outside the bubble and classes is a
great way to do that the professors are
obviously excellent and so it's really a
matter of prioritizing what is important
for you to learn a lot of classmates
take computer science
classes language classes maybe am able
speak more to that um but the class the
levels phenomenal and especially in your
second year you have almost complete
freedom to take whichever classes you
want yeah just to echo what you said I'm
currently taking language classes I took
language classes this year which was
Portuguese now I'm doing Chinese that's
something I like the question is also
specifically about D school classes I
personally have not taken a disco class
yet I do have it however as a really big
priority for my next two quarters at the
GSB I felt the the offering of the G's
people satisfying a lot of my kind of
needs in terms of what I wanted to
experience but I think for the next two
quarters I really wanted to venture out
and on that note the D school has very
often you know information sessions
where they present all the different
classes that are available and if it's
not a class it's a pop-up class what you
do over the weekend dedicate it to a
specific topic so there are different
ways to to kind of engage with the D
school program luckily all right our
curriculum is quite flexible MN allows
our students and take a lot of classes
outside of our bubble and so the next
question we have is how did you decide
to choose Stanford yeah
how did okay that's uh maybe just a
preface a little bit my answer it's
Stanford was the only school I applied
to
and I actually apply two years in a row
I didn't get in the first time I applied
but I was so adamant and so eager to get
into Stanford that I did it again and it
worked out the second time and the
reason why I ended up applying to
Stanford was when during my six years at
Google a lot of the managers I had had
seven different managers managers or
directors and I think three or four of
them were actually GSB alums and I
always knew about Stanford I had a lot
of admiration for Stanford but because
of those managers and because of the
leadership that I experienced to them
this admiration for Stanford became an
aspiration to become part of Stanford
and these these leaders these these
managers were people that not only
influenced me professionally in my
thinking about my career and how I could
show up at work but also very much
personally and that was kind of seeing
the way how they were impacting me and
shaping me and
all these anecdotes that they brought to
work from their time in business school
that really got me pumped and fired up
to to apply to business school so much
that I ended up applying twice so worked
out so let's talk very briefly about why
Business School which is a big part of
my Stanford I was working as I mentioned
in a non-profit in India on agriculture
and was just very frustrated with the
current mechanisms for making change in
those ways policy as we've seen is it's
an intense and often varying process and
so I wanted something that was much more
streamlined and more effective and
business school going through the
corporate sector to influence
sustainability seemed like the way to do
that with that in mind I applied
actually only to environmental joint
degree programs and so Stanford actually
had a program I'd looked at for a PhD
many years before and now I'm doing a
joint degree with the eiper program so
that was an easy fit but honestly one of
the most clear memories I have of when I
was like Stanford is it was an info
session I came to campus I've been
working in SF I came to the campus for
an info session which is part of why I
love doing these and it was really
interesting to talk with the
administrator but then after actually
one of the students who is leading the
session came up to me and was like you
know I see you're from Israel I'm from
Israel do you want to grab coffee can I
answer your questions and she ended up
connecting me to people in the eiper
program and was just a real resource and
a sense of support through the process
and she didn't know me at all and that
for me really reflected the sense of
care and commitment that people have
here and honestly it's only gone up from
there great and a quick follow-up
question since you mentioned doing a
joint degree how does students typically
balance doing that and do you have any
kind of advice for how to do so yeah so
I as I said I'm doing the environment
and resources joint degree and there's
people doing law degrees medicine
computer science engineering a whole
range and each of those experiences are
gonna be different in general the
program is actually really well set up
to accommodate there's almost no
pressure or no additional work that I
have to do it takes longer in my case it
takes extra from one extra quarter to an
extra year and it depends on how you
balance your units but it really comes
down to choices and so you make choices
around how you want to use
course time and do you want to take my
business classes or do you want to go
across the street and those choices will
depend how much longer I end up spending
here but then a lot of other programs
they just integrate it perfectly and
while you're here you're here and then
the rest of the time you're there so
it's been very smooth at least for me
great
another quick admissions question so
would you recommend getting a
recommendation from a professor and what
if you're applying as a college senior
so typically we tell people to shy away
a bit from getting recommendations from
professors typically they do not provide
us with the level of leadership
potential that we're looking for the
level of detail that we're looking for
the biggest kind of exception to that is
if you are working with a professor
doing research or anything like that so
if you are working with a professor
outside of class maybe as a TA or
teaching assistant or as a research
assistant and that may work for you the
biggest piece of advice I typically give
for choosing recommenders is to look at
the questions that we actually ask them
ask that we will ask your recommender
and if that person whether it's a
professor or someone else
can you know for a fact can answer those
questions with a lot of detail then that
is that is okay for you to use that
person so definitely to use your
judgement when you're when you're
picking recommenders next question is
about extracurriculars what types of
extracurriculars are you involved in
here on campus I can take that it's a
it's like it's a good question I do a
lot actually so what I'm so I'm on the
board of four different associations one
is the Diversity Committee which is
dedicated to raising more awareness and
making the GSB a more diverse and
inclusive environment then there's the
Asian business Student Association on
the board of that we actually have our
identity retreat coming up this weekend
in Santa Cruz there's 50 of us going
there to discuss what it means to be
Asian for context we decided that Middle
East is originally I'm from Iran is also
geographically part of Asia and just
just to explain why I ended up there and
then there's there's the Student Alumni
Board where we nurture where we kind of
develop relationships with alumni and I
think the last one is women and
management which is an organization very
very dear to me
we have a very large kind of movement
here on campus which is not only by
women to support and empower each other
but also we have an ally group which is
women it's women and management the man
I like group of it and where men come
together and discuss how we can be more
supportive of women and these four kind
of activities plus there are two trips
I'm organising I mentioned Italy one I'm
also taking ten classmates to my home
country to Iran with Thanksgiving and on
a very personal trip outside of outside
of school and things like that so
there's a lot going on like iki there's
a really no limit to what you can do
extracurricular yeah yeah I'll add so I
was also involved with win last year and
I'm the head of the food and a club but
I think the most important extra culet
extracurricular for me right now is the
Arbuckle Fellows Program
it's a Leadership Program that you do in
your second year and part of the program
is to teach actually a squad of first
year students every first-year student
takes leadership laboratories and that
lab is a group of six which is your
squad and it's led by a second-year
you also do a series of coaching with
one on one with the students and that's
been just phenomenal opportunity to
develop skills of the coach but also to
get to interact with first year students
and practice my leadership I'll also
just say on the side I am a yoga
instructor and so I was teaching last
year yoga classes every week third
classmates at our in our residency of
Schwab so there's just really unlimited
ways to get back and to get involved and
I still have to make it to a class yeah
so I I actually lived in the US for
years prior to starting at the GSB and
what it's like as an international
student so I certainly didn't have the
experience of actually having to move
for the GSB to the GSB because I've also
been living in the Bay Area previously I
certainly I really appreciate it kind of
the number of international students we
have personally I wish we had even more
I think I very much connect very well
with with international students we we
very much also celebrate the fact that
we come from different countries we have
is it this weekend
on Sunday we have a with a big Food Fair
there 15 different countries preparing
food from their nationalities where we
kind of you know celebrate the diversity
the geographic diversity we have at the
GSB I think we and I think that's a
phenomenon that I've seen at schools as
well as at the workplace or in my social
circles outside of school it's just you
people just tend to bond possibly
quicker and in an easier fashion with
people people of their own kind and and
I think these are tendencies as I said
you find everywhere but the good thing
really what I would like to highlight is
that there's not too much of group
formation so people do come together to
celebrate a certain element of the
identity but at the same time this
element is also celebrated by other
groups so if you have a lot of cultural
events that are highly or frequently
visited by also American students or so
for example the Asian Student Business
Association is is very close with the
African business Student Association so
there's a lot of support of between the
different identity groups yes I would
say I don't eat it doesn't really cross
my mind in a day-to-day way not because
I'm not aware of all of our diversity
but because I think there's a really
fluid relationships between people of
all of all places Americans and across
all other kinds of identities great okay
a question about faculty members how
accessible are faculty members and do
you have an example of a meaningful
interaction you've had with a faculty
member since you've been here yeah a lot
honestly so very accessible I have to
just say very honestly this week I had a
50 minutes to walk which is talk and
walk that's how I call it yeah but so we
we just walked and talked for 50 minutes
and he's one of my professors I just
dropped him a line and said I don't want
to pick his brain on some of the
entrepreneurial projects that I'm
currently pursuing just today I signed
up to host a faculty dinner where
one professor would come to our house
and we would host a dinner for him and
and seven other students I would say
they're very accessible they they are
always willing to meet they are always
willing to advise if you have seen in
the past there have also been cases of
professors helping you with funding so
it's very very very close not only do
they know you by name very quickly
because again because of the class size
but they also really care and and I made
it a priority for myself this year to
meet as many professors as possible and
and they're absolutely willing and it's
great I love that aspect
absolutely additional thing I completely
agree with that I think they also go in
a very wide variety of ways to invest in
the community over the past couple
months a very established politics
professor we have here at Q Tennessee
has been doing lunchtime bbl to discuss
the progress at the election
what is bbl brown bag line and so that's
just his way to kind of give back and
answer people's questions and get
involved similarly there's a really
popular class he'll here called managing
growing enterprises taught by Joel
Peterson and there's some students who
don't get into the class because it's a
lottery system and so he this sum this
quarter ended up hosting a series of
seminars at his house and so people who
didn't get into his official class were
able to go to his house and kind of hear
a lot of the learnings that he shared
with us and that just I think across the
board people are really committed and
invested great so how have if at all
have your career aspirations changed at
all from your time here how the hell is
how do you think about that we're
smiling because we were just talking
about yeah so I have actually have
pretty big shift I came in thinking I
wanted to do sustainability specifically
around farm sourcing and sourcing
products in a more environmental and
socially friendly way I did that this
summer I was that blue apron and their
farm sourcing team and I realized in a
lot of ways that the thing that was
interesting to me about that space was
the people I'd been working with I've
been working in India with a lot of
smallholder farmers and it was those
connections that had really motivated me
and less of the food part so I came back
and kind of potentially have scrapped
that entire hypothesis and I'm looking
at much more people focused roles it
and kind of leadership and and
management yeah I came with a vague idea
around entrepreneurship and I was very
intentionally vague about it because I
think these two years there's a lot of
different opportunities crashing into
your life quite literally a single
conversation can change the direction of
your thinking be able to classmate a
class or a professor and I've been
actually very very open to that I I
still want to pursue entrepreneurship I
and I nevertheless decided this summer
to to work in venture capital because I
had I spent my career in technology of
what I wanted to move from the
operational side to the financial side
of the table realize that I don't like
it which now makes me want to look back
into the operational side of things and
what I'm currently working on is you
know one one idea is within within a
class called the startup garage which is
a very experiential class experimental
class based on design thinking very much
and two other ideas so it's still
entrepreneurship and I think the beauty
in general is is that you're exposed to
a lot of different kind of career paths
and other people's career aspirations I
think you always need to be a little
true to yourself and when you enter the
program just have a rough idea where
you're kind of your North Star is
because it with all these different
people who are equally ambitious and and
and and determined it can very happen
very easily happen that you get a little
influenced by that or it's being
inspired it's great but maybe like being
influenced by other people's decisions
is certainly not the best so you want to
have your North Star but be open to kind
of the inspiration coming from your
classmates and I think that's how I've
been faring so far throughout the two
years and just really quickly what are
the resources that you've been able to
happen hopefully been helpful to you and
in thinking about how you pivot yeah so
we have a Career Management Center and
there are career advisors and I meet
with one pretty regularly and I was
teasing her with a group of students
like oh yeah I see grace every week and
she stopped them and she's like no no
Talia actually comes and see me every
week so that's that's a very helpful
resource and then they have a lot of
like visioning workshops and obviously a
lot of different people you can talk to
to help explore and negotiate
thank you okay you already touched on
this a bit Holly about electives and
getting the classes you want so what
does that process like in choosing
electives and you typically get the
craft classes that you want yeah me okay
do you always get the classes you want
most of the time yes but not always and
and I think an important lesson that I
learned throughout my time here is
really knowing what you want and then
once you really know what you want you
prioritize that there's a there's a
election system basically you make those
classes your priority and you you get
them accordingly
I would how I'm choosing electives I the
beautiful thing of the GSB is we have a
huge range of different types of
electives classes that will focus on
environmental topics classes that are
very data-driven classes that are very
interpersonal I kind of touch them into
personal topics I just made the decision
that I want to focus on my strengths not
compensate my weaknesses here at the GSB
so I'm not taking many financial
modeling classes I'm focusing more
philosophical interpersonal type classes
and you know just there's a big variety
my favorite electives so far has been
winning writing with Glenn Kremen who
he's a former New York Times
I think editor for the forum
editor-in-chief of not mistaken and he
had this two week class about you know
just how to become a better writer be it
giving feedback to your employees be it
an op-ed that you write or other types
of content cold emails so we rehearsed
that and there's again there's a big
variety and you can choose them by just
reading the reviews there's reviews
descriptions online but there's also
student reviews about the classes what I
did I asked a lot of my MBA two friends
what did they take what do they
recommend and they all responded and
gave me their lists and I took that as a
starting point I'll just add another my
personal favorite elective has been
interpersonal dynamics which is commonly
known as touchy feely but I am taking
winning writing next quarter so love it
great awesome so a couple quick other
questions about admissions and financial
aid so talking a little bit about
financially and how that works so our
financial aid application happens after
you have already been admitted into the
program so once that happens our process
is need-based fully need-based what that
means is after you are admitted you will
get information about the financial aid
process from our financial aid office
and you will submit documents talking to
us and helping us to understand a little
bit more about your assets and your
income and the level of fellowships that
you will receive will be based on that
information so whether you are a
domestic student or you are an
international student you are eligible
for fellowships we will also talk to you
about loan options as well the other
question is tangentially from financial
aid is talking a little bit about the
youth Stafford USA mba fellowship this
is a brand new fellowship that we have
launched this year and with this
fellowship it is specifically targeting
students that have very strong
demonstrated ties to the 12 states in
the United States that make up the
Midwest region so we have a ton of
information about this on the website we
also have a recording of a previous
webinar we did about the fellowship so
if you have any further questions you
can ask about that
the specific question here is what are
we looking for in a candidate so with
this process you will apply to the
fellowship within the MBA application so
we're looking for at a baseline the
exact same thing we're looking for in
the general MBA application so the
intellectual vitality demonstrated
leadership potential and the personal
qualities and contributions in addition
to that we are looking for you to help
us understand what your ties are to the
region and also the impact that we want
that you want to have upon your return
to to one of those 12 states if you are
interested in the fellowship you must
apply by the round 2 deadline this year
and again for more information
definitely check out our website another
question back to our students is what
has been your favorite experience at
Stanford so far let's start with that
one start tell me good
I guess the highlight is in essence what
I'm taking from that question for me I
was giving a talk talk as a tradition we
have at the GSB every Wednesday night
two students come up and give a talk on
their life the origin actually was I
just found out it was basically someone
saying oh you know there's so many
incredible people here and we don't
really know that much about them because
everyone is so humble and Andy Dunn was
at GSB Nate was like well then why don't
you talk about it and so it really was
just a chance to talk about who you are
and I was fortunate to give I think the
third talk of the year which was
basically talking to a bunch of people I
didn't know yet and from that was
incredible the number of emails and kind
words and people reaching out to really
get to know me and so it it made me very
feel very safe and the community and
also very respected and valued yeah
favorite experience I give a talk as
well and I agree with you Talia that is
an extremely rewarding experience to
show you story with your classmates for
me my highlight however was the GSB show
which is a musical that is entirely
written and directed and produced by GSB
students and it's a comedy you can say
I'm kind of making fun of ourselves here
at the GSB and that for me was a
highlight because not only because of
all the effort that went into it but
also because of this really cool
opportunity to be on stage with your
classmates and and entertain 1,200
professors fellow classmates significant
others and so on and so forth yeah yeah
so so here the funny thing is I was
actually only acting but they gave us
microphones so I had a microphone on my
on my ears or in my face all the time
and I was dancing and why we were
dancing some people in the front were
singing so everybody thought I was also
singing so everybody was kind of
congratulating me on how great of a
singer I am they didn't know that the
microphone was actually offered while I
was dancing but that was personal thing
so okay so question about what is the
best way to prepare to get the most out
of Stanford
for those who are able to be admitted to
the program I asked myself this a lot
still asking myself this it's time as
quickly ticking away on this incredible
experience I think feedback I got that
was super helpful was to spend time with
your loved ones
I cannot underestimate how intensive an
experience is and how little time you
will have to spend with friends and
family outside of this world not because
you don't want to but because your day
it's just incredibly full so really if
you can take the summer or the year
before to spend time with people you
love and give things to prioritize
things will change as we've discussed
but if you can have a clearer sense of
what you're here to get it'll be that
much easier to make the decisions that
flow in almost on an hourly basis there
are so many opportunities with every
hour of your day here and without a
clearer sense of what your priorities
are it's really easy to get swept away
into things that are really cool and
really valuable but maybe not what
you're here to get yeah I really wanna
echo that in and I kind of mentioned
that earlier as the North Star I feel
you should if you come to school you
should have a general idea you should
have a really good idea of who you are
what your values are and kind of stay
true to them throughout the experience
as I said I think there's a lot of
there's social pressures there's social
influence there's a lot of things you're
exposed to that kind of shape your
thinking and if they can really drag you
into all different directions I feel and
but if you know what you came here for
and what you want to get out of it and
if as Talley said if you know your
priorities in advance that that really
helps make does it make good decisions
and and be happy with the decisions you
make great okay well we are coming up on
45 minutes but before we go just sold a
couple last things almost tied to the
previous question any final words of
advice for people who are still trying
to figure out whether an MBA is right
for them yeah yeah it's a tricky
question I there is no right answer I
don't think there is no there's no right
applicant a right student for an MBA I
think an MBA is such a diverse program
in such a diverse opportunity that
people from all different walks of life
can get something out of it
i i once someone once told me you know
you get an mba if you want to lead if
you want to be the executive of a large
organization and and i had that in the
back of my mind when i came to the GSB
but I think at the GSB I realized that
it's not true for me personally an MBA
is an opportunity to challenge my
thinking to make amazing new friends to
take classes that push me and really
also like just have some intellectual
kind of freedom to to pursue things that
I at my time at Google would have never
considered so just one quick example I
was working on developing an investment
thesis for Iran and I wanted to pursue
that over the summer and I worked with
it on a perfect with a professor but
that's something I would have never even
considered while I was at Google but at
the GSB you're exposed to so many great
things that it makes it possible point
being I think an MBA gives you a lot of
opportunities it really comes down to
you if you want to take advantage of
those or not I think that's great the
only thing I will add is in terms of
like whether or not it's right or when
it's right really just try to figure out
who you are and I say that because
that's a huge part of the application
process it's also a huge part of what we
do here I would say more than half my
time is spent on reflection and feedback
to better understand what my strengths
are and what my values are and then to
improve upon those that comes in to play
very strongly in the application as well
so as much time as you have given to
making that decision I would say
personally I allocated a lot of that
time towards just figuring out who I was
and what I wanted and from that I think
naturally decision hopefully will flow
and in terms of timing I wasn't I
started my application in October for
round two
I thought oh I should just wait a year
and forget it and then I thought you
know who cares like I'm just gonna give
it a try and it worked out so not saying
that's the right path but certainly
don't limit yourself just because you
don't think it's the right time for
external pressures great well thank you
so much tally it will need for joining
us and for all of you around the world
for watching you can learn more about
the MBA program on our website and by
watching our videos on YouTube